how do you decide a story's ending
i think deciding your ending is one of
the first things that you should do when
you're thinking of a movie idea
because audiences can forgive slow
beginnings
they can forgive muddy middles but if
the film doesn't have a good ending
you walk out of the theater with a bad
taste in your mouth
so i think that's something that you
really need to think of right from the
get-go
and also because that helps you
build towards something if you know what
the ending of the film is when you start
writing it
you you have your son you have the major
signpost
of what you're building towards and i
think that's really important
because a lot of films sort of fall
apart in the second act
because they don't know where they're
going but if you know right from the
get-go what the ending of the film is
you can you can you know what's up
farther ahead
so and then you can sort of build your
sequences around that and then build
your scenes around your sequences
knowing that everything is leading
towards a very specific endpoint
uh i think that's really important and
so by
outlining that's where you would
discover it
absolutely yeah um and it's nice
outlining is good too because you can
see
if an ending that you've picked doesn't
fit with the rest of your film
like a writer may decide there's a
moment in the second act that i have to
build this film around
which is great you know if it's
something that you're really passionate
about
but it may not work with the ending
you've chosen so by outlining
you can decide okay what are the moments
that i'm going to be building this film
around and how can i get those moments
to help me towards a satisfying ending
if that makes sense have you heard of
the 24 uh plot points
doing it that way we spoke to another
gentleman who's a writer an instructor
or professor
and he talked about the 24 plot points
i may know them under a different name
oh okay maybe that's it
yeah so you're writing down these 24
points and then
plugging in the different things so that
might be actually very similar to
professor edson's uh process because he
has
23 hero goal sequences in a film
okay so that could be pretty close to
that interesting and so that's done
sorry in the beginning so you're mapping
that out
okay and that's your that's sort of your
guide your map
interesting okay and so then that 23rd
or 24th
that's your ending that's your yeah i
mean
normally normally the the last
three to five hero goal sequences are
your ending
so it's not one particular moment but
it's your third act
right so you understand what's going to
happen in your third act as far as what
the major
action through line is and then also
what the emotional
sort of wrap up is for these characters
does this character get what they want
do they get what they're fighting for
have they learned anything through the
experience and you don't have to
necessarily
that's how seinfeld was on the air for
10 years um you know
that however however you want to wrap up
the story
that act is where all those events take
place and that's where all those
questions are answered
so that's that's kind of the zone you
know where you can answer those
questions
so let's say 19 through 23 or 25
yeah yeah it's the according to
professor edson
uh the first act has six euro goal
sequences
the second act has 12 and then the third
act can have anywhere from three to five
so yeah that's usually how it goes so
when you begin outlining
do you go straight to those last five
or no you're just going in order not
always
um like for for the script that i've
been working on for seven years
i knew what the ending of that film was
right off the bat i knew exactly what it
was
and the struggle since then has been how
do i build the film to that
so other films you know i i have an
opening image that i think is really
cool
and that i start with that but then i
have no idea where i'm going so it you
know it kind of depends on the story you
have different inspirations and you know
you have different ideas
of elements that you begin with and then
it's just the
the time that you put in to structure
everything else around those
to create that film that's that's got
the emotionally satisfying arc to it
how do you know the ending's good or
it's satisfying for someone
well one good way is to test it with
people
pitch it to them um i've done that a lot
uh school
taught me that you know workshopping
things is a great way to get out of your
own head
and get other opinions from folks you
know who are also writers and who are
also storytellers
and you know pretty quickly if you pitch
a few people
and you get sort of sideways looks
you know pretty quick that there's
something wrong with with what you have
if it works it works immediately
and that's true with a log line it's
true with any particular moment in a
script
you know if somebody knows a particular
story and you're telling them a part of
the film
you know immediately if it connects so
that's i think that's that's one good
thing um you know if there's any kind of
hesitation
i think that's a point where you need to
go back and review you know what got you
to this point
why do you think this isn't working is
there something you can change before
that
point to make that event more poignant
you know or scarier or funnier you know
whatever it is
but in my experience it's pretty fast
it's pretty quick that you that you
learn
by workshopping whether or not
something's working do you ever change
endings
mid-course like you you know your ending
when you outline and then as you start
writing
you've decided you know what i think the
ending's changed
yeah yeah i've done i've done that i've
i've written films where the beginning
ends up completely changing i've written
films where the lead character becomes
another character
you know it's all it's it's a process
and it's really
trying to figure out who these
characters are and
trying to figure out why is this
character in this story
that's a question that i think you need
to answer when you're when you're
putting something together
um you know if you have a story about
you know like a revenge story
uh about a guy who's trying to get
revenge on song i'm thinking of the film
taken
you know you you think of what kind of
character
would fit best into a story like this
what kind of character has the most to
learn
by going through the experience of this
movie
right so for an example
i have a script that i'm writing about
a woman whose mother is running for
governor
in a midwestern state and
her mother mother and daughter have a
very very stressed relationship
mother's very ambitious she's had a
political career she wants
national office things like that and the
daughter is a very
meek person just wants to live kind of a
quiet life
kind of be you know off to herself to be
involved in
a big media campaign for a big political
office
is a situation that she would feel
really uncomfortable in
so that's why i want that character as
my lead because she will have the most
to learn
by going through that process so it's
finding
you know it's it's finding a character
to match what your story is
and that can you know that can take any
any kind of flavor and it can go
in a lot of different directions reminds
me of um
ingmar bergman's forgive me that for the
name is
escaping me but about the mother and
daughter and the mother is this
classical
pianist or whatever and she's had this
tour and she kind of abandoned
motherhood
and then her daughter is this more meek
i think she might be like a social
worker or something
and she comes back after having been on
the road and even though sometimes if if
you don't have the subtitles that that
are playing just the tension
is fantastic to watch yeah that's and
and that's and for me
families are a great place to find that
that's why i enjoy
stories about dysfunctional families
because you're these are people that
you're around in the formative years of
your life
so any any emotional deficits that you
have or any issues that you have
are primarily because of the folks that
you spend time with you know whether
it's your family or your friends you
know
kind of growing up those are where you
get those formative experiences so yeah
that's why i enjoy
stories like that
you